hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and pimply person
when i was a teenager i assumed i'd grow
out of it and i'd be pimple-free by my 30s
but that was a lie but there have been a lot
of really good products that have come out for
treating pimples that i really wish i had in
my teens and one of the brands i've been using
a lot is zitsticka they make these really neat
stickers for targeting spots and i'm going to talk
you through my favorite products and the science
behind how they work this video is sponsored by
zitsticka but these are my honest opinions of the
products after i've been using them for a while
i've been using the killa patches for a bit over
a year the hyperfade patches for a few months
and the goo getter only for a few weeks but
that's because this is their latest launch
if you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products click the like the
subscribe and the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
let's start with the killa patches these
are microdart patches that are designed
for pimples that are a bit too deep for
regular topical spot treatments to get to
they have a chip with tiny spikes or darts as
they're officially called and this is stuck to
a hydrocolloid bandage the darts have active
ingredients in them and when you put it on
your skin the darts sink a little bit into your
skin and then they dissolve and that delivers
the active ingredients deeper into your skin
closer to where they need to be to deal with
the pimple the killa kit has two parts it has
the cleana cleansing wipes and the killa patches
you clean the area first with the cleana
wipe and that gets rid of oil and dirt and
so the patch sticks down better this also
has actives in it that can help with the
pimples so it's got salicylic acid and tea
tree oil and these can clear out the pore
and help calm down the pimple after wiping
you stick on the patch with the dark side down
the darts dissolve within about two hours and
that delivers the actives so the actives in
this they're salicylic acid again also hyaluronic
acid which is a really great humectant moisturizer
oligopeptide-76 which is an antimicrobial peptide
that's non-irritating and niacinamide which helps
with uneven skin tone obvious pores and redness so
the darts will dissolve within about two hours but
it's better to leave the patch on for longer so i
usually put this on overnight so leaving the patch
on there actually helps the active ingredients
absorb better there's a thing where if you occlude
your skin if you cover it up with something then
active ingredients can get in more easily the
patch also protects the area so you don't pick
at it as much and it stays clean the patch also
keeps the area moist which is better for healing
i like using these patches on medium depth pimples
so not the ones that are like really hard lumps
but the ones that are a bit shallower a little
bit smaller but they're really red and angry these
ones usually take a few days before you can start
to see the pus but i found that if you put this
on early enough the bump sort of goes backwards
with any pimple that has pus in it i
like to put on a hydrocolloid bandage
these are the pimple patches that you might have
seen around they usually come on a sheet and you
peel it off and stick it on a pimple so the
sticky side has a humectant in it and that
sucks up any fluid from a pimple they also
protect your pimples from dirt and they stop you
from picking at them also if they soak up enough
fluid you get this really satisfying white spot
zitsticka have just launched the goo getter
spot clarifying dots these are hydrocolloid
bandages but unlike a lot of the other ones
on the market they also have actives in them
like with the killa patches we have salicylic acid
and tea tree oil and these clear out the clogs and
calm down the pimple there's also niacinamide
that's soothing and helps with uneven skin tone
on top of that there's also vitamin c in the form
of ascorbic acid this is an antioxidant that helps
shield against free radical damage and it also
helps keep your skin tone even as the pimple heals
again we have that occlusion effect when you
cover up your skin it absorbs ingredients better
even if you don't have anything like microdarts
and so having that hydrocolloid combined with the
active ingredients it's a really effective option
there's no cleaning wipe with the goo getter but
because it sits on top of the skin rather than
sinking in then it doesn't really need it as much
you should still make sure that you clean the skin
first though so you don't trap any dirt in there
also make sure your skin is dry before
you apply these products otherwise the
darts on the killer patch are just
going to dissolve on top of your skin
and the goo getter probably won't stick it might
absorb out some of the water and so it's not
absorbing the fluid inside your pimple the goo
getter patches are a bit on the smaller side
so they're good for small pimples but if you have
a lot of fluid these probably won't work as well
i'm hoping that zitsticka will also follow up with
bigger ones too finally there's also hyperfade
this is a microdart patch that targets the dark
spot that's left after your pimple goes away
like with a lot of other asians i'm really
prone to hyperpigmentation after pimples
so it's really good to see products that cater
for this hyperfade uses the same hyaluronic acid
based dart technology as the killa patches but
there are fading ingredients in this instead
so there's kojic acid niacinamide vitamin c
arbutin tranexamic acid and licorice root extract
i've been using these on my dark acne
marks and they've been working really well
i've always had a lot of success with fading dark
acne marks using ascorbic acid vitamin c so i'm
not really surprised that these patches work so
well they have the ascorbic acid and lots of other
stuff so they have the extra active ingredients
they have the darts and they have the occlusion
so i hope you liked this video if you did
you can give it a thumbs up and subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram
@labmuffinbeautyscience and check out my
blog for more about the science behind beauty
products see you next time to nerd out more